hey B before we jump in this juicy
episode dude yeah juicy oh man you're
gritty your te your rat teeth are
showing dude yeah I got some rat teeth
your lemonade teeth you know sometimes
Brandon I just want to take life you
know what I mean specific people but
that's but you're headed to Calgary head
to Calgary to make people make laugh
because you know that's what I do I make
people laugh that's all I've tried to do
uh so November 16 17 18 you come see
this guy at yuck yucks and calary and
then I don't take the next weekend off
Brandon well I do I go to December 7 899
I go to helium indanapolis Indianapolis
I'll be at Helium and then spaan
Washington December 15 and 16 I don't
stop and you know where I'm going to be
in Naples Florida off the hook December
21 22 23 okay yeah so we go Christmas
Yeah Christmas yeah so uh Pasadena this
Thursday sh and friends I got some
monsters with me that's one show only
800m November 16th this Thursday keep on
trucking show starts tour starts
December 8th and 9th two shows Friday
two shows Saturday in Chicago Nashville
January 25th one night one show only in
Nashville Tennessee then I'm in Austin
Texas that Friday and Saturday that's
January 26 27th ticks at thick boy.com
uh the TRX Toontown Series starts
tomorrow 9:00 a.m. Tuesday it's
available for the on the TW toown
YouTube it's my TRX going to a th over a
th000 horsepower turn to the demon TRX
so get you some but do you watch
basketball I mean I do I watch
basketball I watch football college
football basketball all of them dude I
bet on all them how do you do that
DraftKings I'm glad you asked man
DraftKings Sportsbook got your back this
week new customers can score 150
instantly in bonus bets just spending
five bucks on basketball win or lose you
get an instant dub download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
the code fighter new customers can get
150 instantly in bonus bets for betting
just $5 r on basketball only on
draftking Sportsbook with the code
fighter gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler in New York call 8778 Hope and Y
or text heny
46739 in West Virginia visit www.1 1800
gambler. net please play responsibly in
Conneticut help is available for problem
gambling call 888 78977 77 or visit ccpg
do.org on behalf of booill Casino and
Resort in Kansas must be 21 or older in
most eligible States but age varies by
dist by jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and state
specific responsible gamblings resources
eligibility and deposit restrictions of
apply bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance terms at
sportsbook.com basketball terms
yes again F in theid this is really the
fighter in the kid come on baby let's go
let's do this
ready eron this is how we do it back on
fighter in the kid ladies and gentlemen
what's up buddy where we this weekend
you know what buddy I was in Raleigh
North Carolina I want to thank all the
people coming out I missed my Thursday
show don't know if I told you that sold
a lot of tickets on a Thursday too very
very excited and I got on my plane at
9:00 a.m. and American Airlines was like
we have maintenance issues get off get
off get on the next plane it's leaving
at 11:25 I'll just make it we have
maintenance issues I had to cancel my
Thursday show nothing worse nothing
worse fast and and then good luck
telling American anything cuz they're
American and it's like you ever so
American Airlines a big play yeah you
know when the ocean is like the way Wes
are big and you were to go hey stop
being so big with your waves it's
basically the same thing that's I I
never understood I never understood when
Comics you know they miss flights
because we travel so much when they try
to like talk smack to the
Airlines Delta goes cool y so don't fly
with us start a new Airline fly private
oh no go check out Spar fly private but
they L there's nothing like there's no
but they're like okay don't fly we older
planes there so many other people that
are going to jump on board and take your
spot it's like complaining you're the
staring quarterback and the Dallas
Cowboys like okay but also the main guy
charge the guy was in charge he goes I
go another maintenance is he goes
Perfect Storm you know sometimes it's
just the bathroom and the cargo door and
you know I'm
like I don't even know if that's true
but okay he's seen it all I went to I
flew to Arizona on Friday drove back
same day about a 7 hour drive
H it's not the coolest Drive how's your
how's your
when you're doing that your feet hurt or
anything CU I'm getting an age where I
sit like that the muscles I got some
weird [__] going on with my feet no not
at all not at all like just from driving
oh damn daddy you know what is that it's
the Tesla I'm doing this all the time so
I have a repetitive injury I have carpal
can't it drive itself isn't that why you
get those gay things yeah but you know
you're you're not going to do that all
the time do it in traffic it can you can
but if that sun gleam HS there's a lot
of things there are a lot of things a
lot of things a lot of things um it's a
problem it's a problem it's a problem I
got a repetitive injury in my in my shin
muscles I made the mistake cuz I was
telling Ty go dude we're driving through
Arizona you going see a lot of cactus I
said they grow an inch a year I said so
guess how many in how how old the
cactuses are I messed up oh you messed
up it was always folus on for 4 hours
yeah oh I was like okay yeah another
Cactus shut up yep yeah we're all set on
the cactus guessing of the years that
was a two-minute drill my son's now 12
so he's a little bit Macho it's really
interesting cuz he had we I think he had
staff on his leg Yeah you know he's like
hey Dad I have a store on my leg just
happened I'm like what the [__] take him
to the doctor doctor goes that that we
got to get him on antibiotics because
he's doing Jitsu three days a week and
uh so I go so he's he's he he's well
he's terrified of a shot but he won't
admit it so he's like this he's like uh
so uh what do you think they're going to
do I go I think they're going to look at
it and if you you know you might have to
take antibiotics and you know and he
goes you think there's a there you think
that there's a chance I could get a shot
maybe and I go I go uh I don't know I
don't think so he goes you don't think
so it' be so in get a shot yeah then he
goes what would you say what would you
say the probability is would you say
like what would the probability be dude
5050 you know how bad your staff would
have to get to get a shot no then I said
that I messed with them I go if you get
a shot there's a there's a probably a
good chance they're going to give you
what's called a bone marrow shot and he
goes what right the they got to get into
the bone
marrow suck all the you suck and he's
like what why why would they do that why
I don't need that I'm like because they
got to get in the bone marrow and it
really hurts but that you they have
straps for that where they all do how
how do you get staff your body staff is
around everywhere so on the mat if you
have scratch or whatever it gets in
easier yeah so like from the GES or from
velcro ESP she gloves doing a lot but
staff's always around if your Skin's off
if you don't get that taken care of if
you don't show but if people don't
shower right away after the staff can
get in the one time he didn't shower
afterward this was the one time it
happens it's part of the game it's it's
just like it's like getting water in
your air usually it'll be like a little
like a little white like pimple and
that's when you got to know what it is
like you got to pay attention to your
skin it also be that it'll be really
warm around kind of like a and usually
you can take neopor and keep it on there
you know but if it if it gets in sub you
got some issues it's not a huge deal I
know a dude that told a friend of mine
he has staff on his wiener how does that
happen that's possible I'll tell you how
I'll tell you how you want to take this
I going tell you how uh so he was but
[__] and it rubbed the anus wrong and
that might be there's probably a belt
involved that's the only op that might
be one way but actually more heard
anybody having it on their wi more
common is when guys take a razor blade
and they give themselves a little
manscape they shave but it's on the
trunk and it's on yeah but but dou here
double shave here and what happens
is yes and so you you have a razor that
you're just leaving there it's in the
gym it's wherever it is and it had staff
on it now you shave but who would shave
the trunk no she's saying it's on the
tip that's what the dude said I've seen
way too much first 4 has it on the tip
it was on the trunk well that's okay
it's on the trunk sometimes it spreads
though remember it spreads oh no I know
it's it's called
herpeses yeah that's herpes but he was
like trying to navigate around he's like
D I got these spot my wiener man it's
staff I've been wrestling a lot that's
like my Budd and his friends's like oh
huh that's like a buddy you know him he
he's a you know he's a comic guy hav
talked to him a long time but great guy
and he he was he just you know we were
in Vegas and this is probably about 15
years ago and he's just every time I see
him different girl and I was like and
they were all Vegas girls but some of
them were professionals sure all good
and I go um you uh you bagging that
thing you wearing a condom and he goes
nah [__] that never never never never I
go well okay but you know you're gonna
be careful because if you get something
and then you're having sex you're going
to give it to another girl he goes I've
never had any of that [__] I'm think I
think I'm immune to that stuff I go
you've never had Chia G you know he did
he goes he goes he goes i' my my I've
had a drippy dick but that's about it I
go a drippy dick it's called chyia or
goria your wiener shouldn't have a runny
nose no no runny nose yeah your boy is
doing some weird gay stuff I tell
youse k k is a runny dick not magic mind
but it does give you but you know what
well it get your brain thinking so you
don't make those mistakes get a runny
Wiener that's right see if you have a
runny wiener you should take magic mind
not make those mistakes again to not
make those mistakes again get your head
right magic M get your head right that's
what I have talking about the big brain
not the small one yeah it won't clear up
the drip you've got in your downstairs
area but it'll get your head right one
bottle a day keeps the doctor away there
you go guys uhhuh did you were you able
to watch the fights uh in uh North
Carolina I was able to watch the fights
I've got many thoughts on the fights um
wait I I I made my predictions I was
right not that big
deal what did what were your
predictions I predicted I believe that
um the perara um jury fight would not go
the distance and that perara would would
would win that okay I I and and I'll
tell you why and then I definitely said
the Aspen P pavlovich fight was
definitely not going to go to the
distance someone going sleep pav okay
all these are pretty common and I didn't
have a point of view on the the andrad
uh McKenzie dur fight I think
MacKenzie's lost three times andrad is
Mackenzie did it Andra did but and
record she's lost three times oh we
talking about overall lost her last
three yes mcken dur was the B foren was
a big favorite but andr came in looking
[__] crisp and she was patient and
she um keep going we'll get into that uh
yeah and and so I have you want me to
start with that one
androd sure did you see the other two
yes so I thought I thought my my what I
saw with McKenzie D was that she's a
great Grappler and everything
else without she's still not she's still
a little bit new to striking in
comparison and I think that there was
there were there were some wild mistakes
with her chin up and Swinging wild and I
was like watching andraw elbows in and
just firing down down the middle and I
was like this is not going to work out
it was tough to watch McKenzie during
that fight cuz she didn't have the tools
to get her down so then she's forced to
strike and striking so amateur it was
tough to watch yes yes how she's not I
said I said this on the shop show how
she doesn't move to dagistan and just
wrestle full-time be be the kabib of the
women's division cuz she should not be
striking she's not going ja was she was
she was using that jab she was dipping
and throwing that jab not when you fight
but but it was I was like okay she's
throwing a jab it's pretty good jab and
then then in those exchanges her CH get
but then also she she also moving back
like this too all of it was a nightmare
her technique was bad and then also
she's not with pillo anymore which is a
complete mistake she's not mm why uh a
number of things but with uh Daren too
it's like she's so Elite on the ground
but you got to be able to get these
girls down man yeah when you can't get
them down for a strike like yes it's
going to be tough for her to be I think
some like Jessica andrad to like you may
be a lead on the ground but someone like
Jessica andrad can actually she has so
much experience that she can neutralize
your ground game a lot of man if she
goes to the ground McKenzie should be in
some trouble McKenzie anybody would be
in trouble but but andrad is is somebody
who can like a lot of these people could
starting to learn how to like deal with
that they she she got subit her last
fight she's submitted but Mackenzie
Duran's a straight world champion on the
ground if she can just get him down
issue is she has Jiu-Jitsu take down she
doesn't have you know like Freestyle us
wrestling so that's why you're saying
dagistan wrestle wrestle do something
but commit to just getting girls down
cuz the game plan of striking with these
top fives top six top 10 you're never
going to become champ her outlier her
her skill set is to get girls down
submit him but if you're forced to
strike then we get a shitty striking
match yeah yeah anden go from here
you're saying go wrestle wrestle wrestle
go learn she's
30 it's give me tough uh but with
co-main event Tom asnal Sergey pavich
let let me tell you this yeah Tom asol
came out he wasn't able to train the
entire week before the fight he had the
fight on two we notice had a back issue
had a back injury couldn't train at
least a week before came in at 260 cuz
he usually comes in 245 I think or
something uh no he's usually about 50
something yeah he's big yeah but he he
he was basically trained one week and
became world champion well you know
that's also a lifetime of training
lifetime of good training proper
training I was saying that
Aspen so be like I there was a
difference in athleticism you could see
it like there's just a difference might
most it's crazy but also you're talking
about a guy who spars and apparently
holds his own with guys like I don't
know if you ever heard of Tyson Fury uh
I think his name is Remy that K1
champion heavyweight monster these are
his sparring partners so you're not
throwing anything at him he hasn't seen
he's seen the power and but when I
watched him and I watched uh pavage who
terrifying you know with his he's got
crazy reach crazy power but I watched
the difference in like how Aspen was
getting pavas to step wherever he wanted
and he just a lot life on his feet
remember Su had success ear he landed
one two there you see Tom like
oh but what's crazy about Tom ason story
is great he's such a good person but his
father owned a Jiu-Jitsu gym and
theny so funny yeah so Tommy came up in
the Jiu-Jitsu gym obviously a world
class Jiu-Jitsu practitioner then his
dad left a good paying job in England to
just focus on his son and son becomes
world champion Wow when he put that belt
on his dad it was great how cool is that
yeah man he's he's the real deal and uh
and I I before we get into the other
event I'm just going to say that that uh
I think as
is going to be holding the belt he's got
a big challenge ahead of him and uh and
I and I and I'm gonna say a name that
you maybe now now do you think who is
who is his toughest fight J Jones J
Jones hands down not even close J Jones
John Jones because of Jon's
wrestling or striking the greatest fight
of all time everything yeah pick your
poison the best we've ever had yeah
that'd be by far his biggest challenge
it'll be his biggest challenge not even
close I'm taking as BL be tough too I'm
taking Aspen cuz because of uh really
yeah stylistically yeah yeah so I'm I'm
I'm I'm saying I got money on Aspen with
Jon Jones uh because I think he's more
powerful I think he's naturally bigger I
think he's got did Jiu-Jitsu to
neutralize Jon Jones wrestling I think
he's probably better Striker I don't
although J Jones J Jones with that front
kick better stri than J Jones yeah
interesting I know yeah that's terrible
take okay keep going such a bad take I
don't know I listen you know what you're
drinking nobody's a bigger Tom assol fan
than to say
is the greatest of all time he's my new
boyfriend so I should be you just
learned about him this weekend I said he
champ how long ago CH I've watched him
I've watched years ago two years ago I
world champion you're right you're right
you did two years ago two years ago so
but he's now that that's me on his
English nuts yeah to say he's a better
Striker than John is oh what he say
[__] stupid no no no it's not no no
what do we say around the water cooler a
[__] stupid no no no you you don't
understand John John um John striking is
very great very good unorthodox front
kicks elbows crazy stuff 100% never know
you can't really train for a guy like
that he's so Innovative yes yes yes
never lost never lost 30 fights never
lost be gust but you know what Bren shop
DC brenon job he's fighting s's a good
Striker right hold on beat minut I'll
get to that smaller smaller guys he's
fighting Jon Jones now's bigger than he
is Brenan Jon Jones Is Now same size as
he is yes and Guston in the first
fight got almost the better of them yeah
but he lost and then the rematch he got
knocked out sir you're right you see how
stupid oh you still haven't realized
yeah now here's why here's why around
you got to understand [__] stupid you
got to understand this Ain 205 bubba
this is we in heavyweight now and aspal
ain't hearing a peep out of Jon Jones
power but Jon Jones can't even get hit
on the top of the dome by a guy like
Aspen huge huge X Factor now hear me out
again John's got to fight him he's got
to fight him like this because he gets
caught here by those giant guys oh my
God different game is he a good Striker
I I'm getting to s g if you don't how
many punches he landed sirel gone got a
little overwhelmed by the moment got the
moment high level Striker was afraid of
the wrestling doesn't have the wrestling
sure Tom
Aspen is gonna have his hands full with
Mr seral gun god what another stupid
[__] T okay he's gonna and remember
you said that remember you said that you
know what Tommy's gonna do to s what's s
gonna do with his wrestling there is an
issue with that wrestling what about the
jiit he's a two stripe white belt
Jiu-Jitsu is he is he only two- stripe
white they say he's a blue but I didn't
see it got choked out with a front bit
of an issue it's awful listen you know
what I take it back you're right but if
he stands in bangs with serial gun it's
gonna be a problem uh sweeps the floor
with serial gun but I think that's
probably next mean just he takes him to
the ground quickly Tak him down yeah
yeah quickly takes him down yeah u i I
just I still am going with serial gone
because I want to make this exciting now
please put some respect on and I know
you have but you got to put more respect
on ask 's name when it comes to Jon
Jones because you have to admit J
doesn't have the kind of power I never
said John would be I said still Tas I
still have time you still have Tom that
okay because I just think I just I do
think I think Tom's the best heavyweight
in the world how long do I say that I
think in this game ago years ago two
years ago I think in this game you guys
when when guys your size start swinging
and you hit somebody on the top of the
Dome yeah he keep saying top of the Dome
I appreciate it true that's what he got
that's what he knocked pav out with just
now hit him in Temple he hit him in the
top of the head dude I saw it right here
Temple's the one that it wasn't so much
the temple though it was just like off
here it was like almost a glancing blow
it's all it takes you know what Tom's
dad says to him every time before he
goes in the lon don't get hit he's like
I'm a father first don't get hit we
can't you can't get hit do not get hit
especially with Sergey do not get hit
Jesus do not get hit by that Russian
madman Jesus that was nuts I thought I I
predicted Tommy was going to beat him
but I I I said under three rounds and I
thought he was going to eventually get
the submission I didn't picture him
knock him out in 90 seconds what happens
if Sergey pavich goes back and just
fights he goes to Russia and gets Shane
prob
stoned I don't know how they do Russ
ranking what's his ranking does he two
Sergey he's like two he yeah he's top
seon's one I think he's two right um
he's high but he'll get a I mean so we
won't see JN fight for 16 months maybe a
year you'll see him fight next November
December that's soon after a torn pack I
you're talking about more than a
year he'll be yeah usually they say
eight months with John with some
supplements especially usadas kicked
rocked you know he'll be back I bet
there'll be I bet they announc the fight
by October next year but it's going to
be
Stipe it's not Aspen
all let's get to uh it's going to be
Stipe it's guarantee that's the fight
Jon Jones DPE and still they're not
stripping Jon of the belt no do you
think that's do you age that it's a
tough position I don't admire Dana in
this situation you can't strip the grace
ball time of his belt because an injury
but then you also have Tom Aspen who's
your legit Champion if Jon Jones wins
against Tom Aspen I think he like he's
already the best dude even if he lost
he's already the best yeah there's
nothing he beats him it's like what
that's us but this is good for John like
let more contenders get bigger names and
then he doesn't have to retire after to
beat Stipe cuz now I think his plan
before was to beat steep Bay retire let
the division build but now the division
is built asol is right there so he would
maybe we get two fights out of John
instead of one now that's the good thing
that's the that's the thing so Yuri uh
perara I called that uh I just per is
just so big and also I I Yuri is very
unorthodox and it has worked for him um
a lot but I was just like I think a guy
like perara who's
just he's just fundamentally so sound I
just don't think that stuff the dipping
like he would dip and throw that
uppercut you see that once you're like
okay I've seen that all right it's not
that stuff doesn't really confuse a guy
like perara usually it does he landed
too he had success early on my thing
with Yuri and with perara even is and I
I know you're GNA criticize me for this
I don't understand how you're at Mid
distance with your arms that low I know
that I know that you're threatening
takedowns I know you're keeping your
hands down cuz you can't see the punch
is coming I know there's an MMA factor
to that but when you're in mid distance
with guys who can hit like that and I I
was watching eruri like stand here and
punched this close I went I was like I'm
not a genius but he's going to get
caught with a left hook or a right right
hand I called it I was like there's no
way he's not going to do that in that
exchange plus he's doing it with a
bigger guy and lo and behold that's not
rocket science and I know it worked for
him but it's like I don't get that world
champion that yeah but until you two
chion until you come up against perara I
know and I think by the way same thing
when I was watching perara but also you
your all up on Strickland's nuts with a
Philly shell and his hands down world
champion but there's at least there's
this you know at least there's that
hands down you know his hands not but
he's got one hand up the Philly Shell's
different cuz you're protecting with
that then yeah as long as one hand's up
yeah because you're using your shoulder
you're covering your body you know what
happened with stly when he's doing that
yeah he got knocked out by Yeah by a
much bigger guy doesn't matter you got
knocked out yeah but overall I think you
know I I I just think it makes common
sense to be here at Mid distance if
you're if you're exchanging call your's
Camp let me know how it goes you know
what I'm saying like hey year we know
you're a world champion it's gotten you
the number one ranking get your hands up
you know what I'm saying it's just what
it's not that's why he's great it's not
what they do not though I think he gets
not I mean he's very athletic they F
times that fights five and five oh no I
don't agree yeah I don't think so I
think that the the problem is that you
can fight a guy who's bigger like perara
he's not that much bigger Bubba he is
he's heavier he's just heavier and
you're you're coming in there fighting a
guy at Mid distance with your hands down
like perara I think he's perara is just
a higher level Striker you could make
that argument he's a higher level
Striker yeah and I think you're going to
get caught with that left hook of that
right hand again in the exchange 10
times out of 10 yeah so so if that fight
had gone another five minutes oh I have
a question if that fight had gone
another five minutes I think the same
thing would have happened in that fight
eventually yeah he playing a dangerous
game yes but do do you think that
stoppage was too
soon it's here's why none of this
matters cuz Yi was like there was the
right stoppage I was out wow yeah so
there's no conversation now if Yuri was
like this is ridiculous they shouldn't
have stopped it then yeah let's talk
about it but when the fighter goes I was
out the ref can see his eyes the ref is
looking at the guy's eyes well we all
saw he was out and then and then the the
guy doing the dominating the the more
dominating position is on top and mount
and the guy's out on his feet that's
trouble buba but it's a world
championship fight right you gotta let
him he somersault and was right back up
but not but he was still off when he got
up he was pay beond eyes did him a favor
I think like that's live a fight on a
date it is a world championship fight
you got to let that go a little bit
right yeah and real quick just so in his
she wants see guys die but I don't I
don't but so you know we've seen Yuri
fight before he he actually got knocked
out and wakes up and then beats his
oppon he been knocked out before back
even that that uh postf fight speech he
said that yeah I was out it was a good
call but I never give up I will come
back so he even said like but for a ref
imagine that I know what I'm saying he's
been knocked out before so I was going
to let it go but so it's like tit fight
though title fight a little bit more
just a title fight with overall I would
like to see a few shots land on top I'd
like to see more concussion on top okay
now now that's why we're talking about
Jim when you put it like that it's like
man I just like to see him get a couple
more concussion I'm saying like Okay if
we're going to be putting ourselves in a
position a position to get concussed if
you're working your entire life to get
to this point give me that opportunity
you know or live the fight another day
Yuri wins one more he's right back there
I don't know I felt like it should have
want I agree my initial Instinct was
like ah I was a little early but then
when y got on there was like no I was
out that's I'm fine with the stop his
arms like he no the guy but he's he's
shown that before finish him no he's com
back well if Yuri said I was out it
doesn't matter now he's got the problem
is Alex is Mount yeah that's where it's
di if it happened then yeah [__] stop it
stop it like couldn't I mean he did get
you know the twer get up there y Yuri
picked him up and brought him right to
the ground he won the first round you
could say close the leg kicks really did
a lot of damage really took away his
like awkwardness those leg kicks were
the difference close first round yeah
but you're right those leg kicks would
have just big difference now now
um um uh now perara fights uh what's his
name Jamal Hill yeah Jamal Hill just to
his Achilles two months ago is he still
I thought it was two months ago two
months ago oh sh Maybe Remax but you're
out for a hot second out I thought he
was ready to go no no no he's done
that's a long time that's a year right
yeah yeah and 8 to 12 months before you
can start training right I mean July
14th 2023 so okay so so you got June
July August September October November
so four months ago so yeah you're
looking at late next year yeah never
mind and then you start training on it
so you're looking at what I mean two
years no no not two years he'll be back
next year but ax isn't going to wait for
that he called out Izzy which is a great
call out it's not going to happen but it
just gets I he you know the
fireback yeah who does Alex fight next
uh he could fight racki he could fight
Johnny Walker Anthony
Smith Anthony Smith I haven't heard from
in a
while the Johnny Walker one's the most
exciting one that's the most fan
friendly one
well I think uh actually anv is the one
who's going to be the champion
eventually and I think anv was doing to
Johnny Walker he was going to finish
Johnny Walker in that fight God it's so
hard to tell but that was so early uh I
think see much at all you saw I feel
like you saw an's not gonna let him
become Champion you have all these fun
Strikers and you're going to toss in
that [__] they're not going to let
him he's going to make that road so
tough for him really you think they're
just going to toss him to alexp and ruin
their star he's stupid huh I bet you
they will no no chance huh they going
give him the John Fitz treatment you
can't sell it yeah but how do you how do
you keep him from that after a while
easily he's got what Doan he's number
two it doesn't matter well but who's oh
you think rankings matter Bubba well
well but he's got to fight the number
two guy no he doesn't in what world you
fight whoever they want so you just let
magama just sit there on the vine that's
exactly what they're going to do cuz you
can't if you can't sell pay-per-view
they're not going to let him be Alex is
a massive St now yeah but you could make
him a well it's like khabib he's like a
[__] you know khabib giant
khib no he had he had the draw then he
had the [__] no contest the UFC is
like no no no so he's just going to sit
there they're going to make it very
difficult for him yeah same way the the
Curtis blades they made it very
difficult for him guys that aren't that
exciting that sell pay-per-views you got
to become undeniable before they give
you your shot undeniable have to go
through you got to walk through fire
rankings do not matter
the sooner you realize that the better
off you're going to be in this game do
you Dana doesn't go okay 21 43 no Alex
Pi jumped from 15 to four homot went
from on rank to five it's what can we
sell that's what it is it's matchups
it's p It's
Entertainment and mared's a tough
[__] sell yeah and he's also a
nightmare to fight yes and no I mean you
know he's had some tough times too like
he's not doing himself any favors with
the draws and the contest so UFC is
going no no no give give him three
horrible fights now you win those like
all right give him a goddamn title shot
but by that time Alex is Off to the
Races they're GNA make it super
difficult for
him so who do you think Alex
fight uh either Johnny Walker or um
Anthony Smith Anthony Smith is more
available because Anthony Smith and him
have a beef too so there's a story there
a bit of a story but
raki is scheduled to fight but we could
make that vakit and Yan supposed to
fight raki vers uh Alex is a great
fight I don't know there's so many oh
he's so fun Savage really Savage Striker
oh Savage yeah raki y like light
heavyweights great they they want what's
better for Ratings is those highlights
those strikes just that Kung Fu [__]
going on don't say Kung Fu no it's Kung
Fu God that's what they want kicks
punches you've not trained the kind of
kung fu that I'm talking about you just
have they just want entertaining fights
that sell
pay-per-views
um even like khil he's at 11 but khil
and Alex kickboxing oh khil wins one
they're going to give him they're going
make sure he gets up
there
shut they make it very difficult if
you're just you know if you're not
exciting yeah they they just give you
the worst matchups
you I I mean get it you know it's not
like March Madness no I uh I'm I'm not
not as excited ever at the 205 I mean
I'm not as I am like say 55 or 70 oh 205
is great right now buddy I don't not not
as good as 55 I think 55 is just higher
like level of skill I think well the
lighter weights in the history of
fighting are always going to be yeah
especially 55 is just [__] 5570 is
great 85 is a little dead with hot's in
there then light heavyweight and
heavyweights coming who do you have
against uh what P's uh
Strickland I don't know that's why it's
the most exciting fight out of the three
Dana announced so they announced Alex
and toia he announced um Shan uh sugar
Shan Cheeto then he announced that's in
March then he announ Sean Strickland DDP
the the other ones I can kind of give
you an estimate how they're going to go
this one I don't know because I'm I
don't know I'm on Sean's nuts he's so
good but was it a case of is he having
an off night is you know just had his
night or is Sean that [__] good cuz
if he's that good DDP is not going to
hit him he's going to piece him up but
DDP hits [__] he's huge and he hits hard
and he's just unconventional he just
comes forward like he's a Savage dude
that one I don't know I don't know I I
couldn't call it that's the one F I
can't I have no idea how that's going to
go I have no clue I know how high am I
am on both of them Team all B
too yeah got some tits on him got that
one I don't know yeah you a dog in that
fight you know I'll just go I'll go with
Strickland thanks man [__] you hell yeah
I I think I think if anybody tries to
stand a bang with Strickland punching
Wise It's you know it's going to be
tough for him Alex did it
mhm but dup I would say dupia hits
harder than anybody stricking fight
really good God yeah hell yeah he's just
so awkward but it works for him he just
comes forward I I have no I don't know
how to call that fight that one's tough
we'll
see I mean by the way part of what makes
Shan Strickland such a people's champ is
that he's vulnerable that it's like we
were all surprised he beat this this
incredible you know I mean israela one
of the greatest so it's like it's not
that we haven't seen Sean Strickland
lose and it's not that that it would be
it was surprising that he won so if
dupes beats him it's not going to be
like what you know no yeah you know
that's the only one I don't know how to
call that one that one's tough to get a
read on very
tough very very tough yeah best fight
out of the three all three of them are
freaking ridiculous fights but that
one's tough yep that one's the most
exciting one for sure that's in January
I think it is January in Toronto right
they're doing Canada got a South South
African and American fighting in Toronto
Canadians like we'll take whatever
dude they're just stoked they're getting
fights I
know yeah January
20 gen
20 and then one of the pay-per-views is
in LA right Jen they think they think
that Alex volkanovski versus Toria might
be oh that's what Nick Davis says
interesting Nick usually knows he knows
who's volosi against who uh sorry Ilia
tapa who is a badass fight some people
are saying it's like a little too soon
for volcanos since yeah I'm not crazy
about it
but tough fight yeah I'm sorry when is
that fight Fe um yeah let me look
February I think you're right other no
I'm right it's February then other yeah
I'm right yeah I know for fact right and
by the way I'm 56 I have to still go
October
November oh me Summer I'm like was right
Fe 17 well that would be 10 months from
now
I Feb 17 and it's it's rumored to be
either in Vegas or LA but it seems like
it's it might be in La which would be
dope for
us are I mean are you going to go CH if
we don't do a fight companion be Iraq
for
me fights might as well be in Iraq I
don't give a
[__] you mean you just don't go to
fights I know that's fine I can't admit
if you went to a fight you'd be you
couldn't even walk around it would be
horrible yeah yeah I'd rather watch at
home yeah let's a little break dude cuz
look with everything going on in the
world you got War inflation the economy
dude things are crazy and right now
could be the best time ever to diversify
your money and savings with precious
medals like gold and silver get your
Scrooge MC had gold ever give you gold
and been like I don't want to that gold
it's very rare you know what I mean like
no gold nah it's not worth anything
anymore says no one ever ever ever and
my friends at Gold Co they could have
made it any easier gold cold has helped
thousands of people place over 2.5
billion and gold and silver they're
rated A+ by the Better Business Bureau
and that's just mention a few of their
accomplishments there's so much more
right now the fire and kid listeners
they're offering you guys up to $10,000
in bonus silver while supplies last go
to Gold code.com fighter to learn more
we don't talk a lot about money on this
show but this stuff's important so go to
Gold code.com fighter today that's gold
code.com fighter get your scrooge. on
find out how you can get up to $10,000
in bonus silver wall supplies last at
Gold code. / fighter or call 855 928
now yeah I'd like to companion for those
I would go to that I haven't been to a
live event in a long time last one I
went to I went to won Championship but
then last one I went to was that one
championship in
Denver yeah yeah
yeah UFC is popping though it is popping
I was just thinking of that I was like
there are a lot of fights I'm so psyched
to see it's popping but there there's
that lawsuit going that nobody wants to
talk about that lawsuit's deeper than
people think wait cuz now it's going to
court which one the antitrust antitrust
lawsuit that's G that's gting a lot of
ground a lot of steam theti mean they're
the only Monopoly and and the way they
treat the they like 300 Fighters that
are on that lawsuit oh so they had to
release all their physical financials
like the financial all that we didn't
get privy too so had to release all that
financial information and here's where
it's weird so it's funded um it's headed
by Kung Lee remember all those guys and
John Fitch right so in most cases a
company like UFC is going to settle out
of court cuz the risk is they go through
the lawsuit they're going to end up SP
paying $5.2 billion which I don't give a
[__] how big your company is that's
going to hurt you destroy you how much
5.2 billion sir so usually companies
would settle for whatever two billion
three billion so they don't get exposed
for the 5 billion but these Fighters
aren't doing it for that reason no it's
a so they it's going to go to court and
they're going to win you think so
yes wow cuz UC could just make go away
usually like here's well usually when
that happens they break up the UFC they
will break you up into different
companies it's not good but you should
be paying attention to this it's a much
bigger deal than people think wow it's
been going on for years and they're
finally getting to this point
M
wow yeah
that's pretty wild yeah yeah it could
get really dicey it was a matter of time
before lawyers got involved with that
where like you know Fighters dude
they've been fighting this for seven
years eight years more than that more
than that I mean I think I've been
hearing about well Fighters pay I mean
I've been hearing about well no no I'm
not talking about fight I'm talking
about this lawsuit B that's been going
on for seven years that's how long it's
taking to get to this point well a lot
of powerful interest and could get dicey
for the UFC I think what UFC might do is
go we're selling Saudi Arabia C
that would
suck you know yeah hope he doesn't ruin
the UFC that would really suck yeah
they'll figure it out though yeah guys
just go missing they'll figure it out
what do you got Jen all right the first
thing is we talked about this last week
about jelly roll so he did win the new
artist of the year for the I have the
speech here it's one of the best
speeches you could ever hear so good so
we'll play it for you guys right now
importantly there is something poetic
about a 39-year-old man winning new
artist of the year I don't know where
you're at in your life or what you're
going through but I want to tell you to
keep going baby I want to tell you
success is on the other side of it I
want to tell you it's going to be okay I
want to tell you that the windshield is
bigger than the rear view mirror for a
reason because what's in front of you is
so much more important than what's
behind you let's party
nville like a farmer only convention
that sounded like like he
was CH looks like a trump R he's going
to be a preacher one day he's so good at
dude he's he's awesome that was
beautiful yeah so good he's awesome he
got a Grammy nomination too he just
found out yeah dude it's a very like
emotional dude he's destroying right now
he couldn't get bigger I'm not sure if
I'll post this or not because I'm so
emotional
but the greatest
honor an artist can ever
hear is if they've been nominated for a
gramy I got to hear that this
morning what a good
guy I gr like here since my daddy
died
I tried to make this video seven times
y'all I love y'all
man so [__] much I'm not sure about
yeah dude he's the best what a great
that's our boy video I got the best
people on the planet
yeah you're going to make that video
promoting [__] for coming out you piece
of [__] me that's crazy though jelly
think about it how long you know chin
and how how awesome he's it been to all
of us like what the [__] so he's a great
man all righty uh Georgie got this one
this is just a fun flop I saw from
college
football and
now you got to sell it sequence at the
line why he do yeah he's just beautiful
display of
athleticism he's all oh power that's
great uh and this one I think okay guys
Lane kein got a little grumpy uh in the
locker room he was trying to get a hold
of this player this player didn't want
to show up and after a couple weeks of
trying to get him to come to the locker
room he finally did and this is what
Lane had to say if you would have come
here when you kept getting messages the
head coach wants to talk to you and you
saying I'm not ready to talk to him I
wasn't well what world do you live
in I don't see why you got to be
disrespectful honestly get out of here
go go you're off the team you're done
see you see you because I'm see you go
go and guess what we can kick you off
the team so go read your rights about
mental health we can kick you off the
team for not showing up when the head
coach has to meet with you and you don't
show up for weeks okay we can remove you
from the team
it's called being a it's called hiding
behind and not showing up to work if you
would have come here when you kept
getting messages the head coach wants to
talk to you I think that's it replaying
it I don't have a problem with it I
don't either I don't either well if you
don't show was this kid recording the
coach of course course that's what he's
trying to do and get people to rally is
the guy of course going to get in
trouble no absolutely not good because
it's get out get out of hereu [__]
Sports yeah and also you're full of [__]
those weaked individuals It's Just
Sports is in for you you have mental
health all good man then don't play
football don't play on that team no
one's you allow them allowing you to
play football as a privilege also also
I'm sorry but you may have mental health
totally understand it doesn't mean you
don't show up to talk to the coach no
you you sorry and by the way if you if
many lean into the you can't be on you
can't be on that's why I'm if I'm laying
I'm going if your mental health is so
bad don't be on the [__] football
injury that paid for your College
tuition and gave you all this notoriety
this is a privilege and if you can't
show up for a meeting we have a 30 other
guys who will do it that don't have your
weird struggle dude yeah I I would kick
him off the team immediately he's
leaning into the mental health thing and
then he's recording it so he gets
sympathy but he's a piece of [__] yeah
that's all that is he's just a he's been
he's a little spoiled baby these spoiled
brats are in for a rude awakening when
they think they can lean into the mental
health side of things in sport well so
are PE so are kids in college so all
these kids in college that major in
things that don't matter and have been
and believe that the world is victim
victimizers but then in the real world
like I don't get I can't make money it's
like nobody's going to hire your dumb
ass nobody likes you you're just a
[__] in general [__] out of here
you're you're taking up
space it's all they're all being lied to
in
college all right here's the next one so
this guy uh got out of his car at the
drive-through at McDonald's and he was
really upset cuz they didn't give him a
apparently like hot enough fries and he
went a little ape Yep this is what
happens when you're hungry you
this but also just give him his fries so
he gets the [__] out of
it it down right
now
is give me some food he's drunk yeah
he's not all
there is he on the Old Miss football
team
too oh
wow yeah I think he's
hammered drugs or something hey bro the
fries are good they're not this
good food it's coming out cing give me
some Fri give me that bag Fri right
there grab can you imagine these guys
just making minimum wage dealing with
this though she's like they huming he
he's literally he's he's literally Los
there he's literally losing his
mind another stupid
white take cut white or
black oh he went racist with it too what
did he say w I didn't hear cuz even
after he gave him his fries he went
racist with it yeah did he what' he say
uh some black and white I don't
something about America huh something
about fries Burger Kings are better yeah
by the way business isri be equ with
pepper spray and tasers true yeah they
should just tase the [__] out of them do
you guys have that uh I sent the you and
Rogan our group chat with Eddie in uh
Tarzana they found that woman's torso
you have that on here we yeah actually s
yeah s SAS had it last week they that
they found body parts it's like really
close to here too get ready for this
here we go I'll fill you in on this so
this is first report and then it's on
TMZ now so this they found a woman's
torso in Ino and dumpster and it's come
out that it's Sam Haskell's son he was a
big agent in La um like Dolly part and a
lot of people and apparently his son's
wife and in-laws have been missing and
he hired some day laborers to take the
bags and throw them away the day
laborers open the bags and we're like oh
there's people in here so we're going to
call the police and here's some video
footage of them trying to get rid of the
bags of the day laborers the day
laborers are getting the bags in this
video it's hard to see but um
yeah you see the they apparently went
down the street and then got curious and
opened the bag and was like this doesn't
check out aren't her parents missing too
it's the wife and the in-laws I think
they found they found their bodies cut
up too so he he got pissed and just went
to town on three of them killed didn't
touch the kids them too it's a white
dude three Asians yeah his wife was
Asian they're Asian oh wow I didn't know
that now you don't you chin what the
hell dude no man I'm wow are you kidding
me when it was all white you weren't you
weren't so hype about this guy so dumb
I'm going to get rid of I'm going to put
them in a garbage bag and put them right
outside my house he didn't put outside
his house he put it like down another
street but then some dude was going
through the the oh terrible idea but the
guy was going through this uh looking
for recycling and open up and saw a
woman T so didn't they they hired like
some workers the H day laborer guys take
the bag no no no no the daily the the
day labor guys were like no we're not
taking this they brought it back they
brought it back and then they went to
CHP who was like you got to call the
LAPD we don't deal with this but
originally all this what started was he
dumped it himself part of the Torso
behind this place of business this
person homeless I don't know going
through looking for recycled cans opened
the bag up to look for cans and found a
woman's torso called the cop so that was
the first report dude and they found the
parents too her that's why I hear they
found the parents body parts now have
you seen the guy though who did it his
videos I think they're taking down now
on Instagram Wild Boy like out to lunch
wild oh crazy yeah let's see hold on
they're down but I'm sure you can find
them chin hit it there he is and then
here's the plot twist I'm totally
superficial yo shouts out to LinkedIn
for just making it like so much more
streamlined for me to be told no
repeatedly like my resume says unhappy
bitter
resentful um and like really good at
ordering off the
menu shouts out to the waiter at the
restaurant above Nordstroms for just
like completely burning out of my th
like what kind of a monster are you how
what kind of monster are you I can't
even imagine reading one of these
homeless people's signs it's very BR
Cooper trying to like reconnect with
arena shake like oh my God he sorry
about four y sh talk to my big homie for
like buying me camel lights throughout
middle school and high school I now have
lemonade colored
tea seems totally normal chances are you
want more you good random letters and
numbers T conference real quick you guys
by mistake and the number one thing they
talked about was consistency like be
consistent now I'm consistently never
going to stop drinking shout out okay
this guy's funny is a game developer
game designer educator he's an
entrepreneur I'm literally dumping
entire bags of shredded cheese into my
mouth yo shouts out to Bella Thorn
Beyonce for literally making it by
having a tattoo of an
avocado my goal was to try and drop some
lbs by just like not eating any more
breakfast burritos but instead I decided
to just spend less money and to do that
I'm just going to stop buying water at
arowana on a scale had last
how in need of a career reset are you
because I am he's actually funny he's
clearly not doing well he's actually
funny though I hate to say it kind of
reminds me of some he's actually got a
great sense of humor oh yeah I agree you
do you know what I mean yeah
sociopath there is he he killed didn't
he three people oh no and they found him
at the Tanga Mall oh that would make you
a he got caught they caught him at the
Tanga Mall hiding out I wonder what he
what was going on with him he has two
kids two kids yeah that's associate
about but also um he's funny but also he
was like making fun of himself and being
silly yeah but he's a killer shouts out
to my homie making me smoke and that's
why I have lemonade colored teeth yeah
and so I'm going to be consistent and
never stop drinking he's a [__] I
mean murderer funny what happened dum
dum anyway I I mean you know got lost
and obviously has some serious mental
issues and he murders and cuts people up
you know how crazy you got to be to cut
your wife up and then her grand I have
anger I have anger issues I've never in
my life like I have murderous anger
issues sometimes but I've never in my
life been like I'm going to cut you
up like yeah no [__] I [__] hope so
dude but I mean I love how you like one
thing I want to make very clear I would
never cut my wife up and well but I mean
Mur you can have a freak out and and
flip out but but I'm more likely to hit
myself I'm not going to hit you it's
like yeah cuz you're not a sociopath
killer
dude wow you know you know you don't
need to make that distinction right you
know you don't have I want to be very
clear man I get very upset and I think
about killing people I would that I'm
saying you have anger issues and flip
out but you can't flip out to that
degree yeah
cut cut who knows to kill all three of
them is clearly all planned 100% you had
to bleed the bodies you got got to buy
like I used to watch Dexter I mean you
got to have like a saw the whole room he
was like Robin Hood he was killing bad
people this guy's killing good people
that a real that is a product of a lot
of money in Los Angeles where you just
were that is classic La I I I don't
think so man I don't think classic La is
kill your wife and CW I've never heard
of Hollywood cutting his wife up yeah
you're being too cool to him but right
Brian's like he's too bad he's gone I
have him open for me it's not that out
of your [__] mind dude I'm saying
that he's he's he talks like a kid who's
grown up like he he talks like a valley
girl oh my god oh totally shout out to
the guy who gave me cigarettes when I
was in high school lemonade cheese to my
homie who is like I'm just going to but
I thought he was I'm going save money
stop buying water a that's funny that's
a funny joke funny for a cereal
buy probably the funniest killer we know
yeah we don't know yeah that's fair
funniest killer we know funniest killer
F kill funniest funniest mass murderer
we know cuz I think more than three Ted
bunny was pretty witty Ted bunny was
pretty witty yeah but I don't know if
three is a mass it's three or more no
but that's a lot that's yeah oh I think
mass is five okay how about this
funniest Family killer we know funniest
guy who Slaughters entire family
funniest wife killer we know well wife
in-law
killer you
know
yeah well anyway who cares about this I
do I can't believe I I I was relieved it
wasn't like a seral killer on the loose
though cuz so close to my neighborhood
when I found I was you know this one off
I'm like oh thank God cuz if it's like a
seral killer on the like kids aren't I'm
not taking my kids to school I'm not
risking that say what's the first thing
cops do when when they see when they
find a murder a victim they look at if
it's a woman they look at the husband
always always the first one always as a
wife that'll teach you not to talk back
though won't it that will teach you not
to talk back because you'll not be
alive yeah that's yeah that's
dark that's very dark there there I had
I told this actress said one time we
were talking we were talking about the
me tooo movement and all the stuff and
how women are going bad on men I was
like some women hate men and then they
they ruin their reputation and then she
looks at me and she goes know and when
men hate women they kill them like yeah
that's true fair fair point both are
kind of death Fair Point yeah both are
death sentences one you don't have to
watch one really a death one you don't
have to watch to the destruction yeah
yeah what else you got chin um so we
we'll show you this one first this is
another one from son Jesus L wanders the
streets in Italy after escaping the
circus dude in America they can't have
lines I was just at the circus there's
no line you can't have live animals
circuses look it up it's
Italy holy [__] that's a full grown male
lion is that Italian or Chinese giant
male lion
Italian Lion at the size of that thing
just a giant kitty cat was that
Chinese mamaia the lion you can tell
it's a tell you now right a little bit
but got pretty Chinese there imigrant
okay
Mama let's let's finish with this your
boy BR you are so mad I post this like
did on the 90th floor dud harness dude
he was a harness like you do it
yeah clearly I'm joking how bored is
Jared Leto
well he's smart with it if I have to
promote a special by climbing the Empire
State Building we're not promoting this
is that he's climbing that's the Empire
State Building yeah yeah the top part of
it so he started down people like he
didn't even climbed the whole thing weak
the so what that's cool I think that's
cool it's my thing if you're Jared let
hey bud it's also kind of scary by the
way how much attention kind of it's
hugely scary he has a rope though where
Cas so if you fall off either way I'm
scared of height so that scared the [__]
still insane rope or not I'm still just
if you're you made it Bud we don't have
to do all this wild [__] anymore notice
steo is not putting hot sauce in his eye
anymore he's made it yeah not's getting
bored though be that's all it is he's
bored as [__] this is no different
entertainers like billionaires they go
see the Titanic they climb Mount Everest
he's climbing Empire State Building he's
just bored yeah he's sick of [__]
that's what it is oh my God cuz that
used to keep get his rocks off now he
has to clb you figure you figure he did
a lot of [__] do girls girls like him
I know guys do am I right that's it
buddy bri can you explain cuz I'm sure
people going to ask about your nose can
you explain real quick oh I was shooting
uh in Raleigh my boy Shawn shout out to
Shawn who was in the
military uh and he was nice enough to
have us come out and shoot what happened
to your nose dude and I was shooting all
different weapons sh all different
weapons I got a little too close to the
scope yep I got I was trying to I was
trying to get a little to
well and I sent it to our boy Kyle
Morgan who's Delta guy and he was like
you're giving me an aneurysm with your
finger on the [__] trigger Oh you
mean he doesn't know what he's doing and
Annie stump was like your it would be
difficult to describe how bad your form
is please never record yourself shooting
again he loves to torture me but I was
getting super close to the scope cuz I
wanted real accuracy and it went gang in
my nose and I was like I was like ah and
then and then I don't get embarrassed
but I was like ah not a big deal and I
was I could just see the blood and I'm
like ah [__] damn it like damn it my dad
my dad always talks about I was a marine
I was a sniper okay we he buys that some
[__] elk gun bear gun 370 so loud
when you shoot it outside you have to
keep your mouth open it'll blow out he's
so [__] loud and he's lying down on
the ground he's kept saying I want to
site my rifle I want to site my rifle
we're in Alaska he shoots the gun and he
just goes like that I see him do that
and and I and he just looks at me like
that he's got a [__] perfect circle
he looked like a [__] half a raccoon
the whole time it cut it cut such a deep
cut right through it he was just like I
was like you look I thought you were
Marine you Marine thought what happened
snip s just I was I'm used to shooting
that yours is like this hilarious and it
blew your hair back too huh oh dude
guess what we didn't do we didn't we
didn't hunt bear anymore and I shot that
thing once and I was like oh my God it
was so [__] loud I couldn't even I
was like oh Jesus you know no thanks no
thanks uh guys this weekend yuck yucks
uh Thursday Thursday Friday Saturday
Calgary at yuck yucks I'm coming back I
love Calgary my boy Brad Forte open up
Thursday night yes Brett Forte will be
there yuck yucks Calgary and then
Indianapolis helium I'll be there
December 7 8 and 9 can't wait to see you
guys and in Spokan Comedy Club December
15 Daddy's busy in September a road dog
yeah December December stays on the road
uh what you doing for Christmas Bubba I
don't know man let me get through this
uh passing Ice House shoing friends this
Thursday one show only at 8:00 p.m. got
some monsters on that show that's one
show only at 800 p.m. in Pasadena and
then the keep on trucking tour starts
December 8th and 9th that's two shows
Friday two shows Saturday keep on
trucking in January for 2024 uh starts
in Nashville that's a Thursday January
25th one show one night only and then on
Friday Saturday in Austin Texas January
26 28
we got Edmonton we got uh Vancouver on
there Plano Texas I'm all over thick
boy.com new episode the debut episode of
Toontown starts tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. on
the Toontown YouTube it's taking my TRX
turn to demon TRX over a th000 horse
power we got kib Tech we got overkill on
there method uh toyot tires we got
everybody involved it's a fun old time
and this is the first episode so stay
tuned debut is tomorrow at 9:00 a.m.
Toontown YouTube baby I love it baby you
like that lightning huh you jumped in
Brian's like oh my God you felt oh that
thing is just man that's a
truck what do you got under This Hood oh
man I told you that time I was like I I
pulled in the gas station I wanted to
have something in common with the guy
hell of car man I was like look at that
engine he had an engine on a block go
what the hell is that look at that thing
man look at that engine man kind of what
horsepower is that I go what what do you
put that bad boy into and you know what
he said to me goes it's a boat
engine swear to God I swear to God I've
never been more embarrassed in my life I
was you know how I you know how I try to
talk sports or like engines well what's
up man you putting that monster like
like when when I'm talking about hunting
I I act like I know guns I use win ma
300 what do you what do you guys use
like that's all I know you know same
thing geez look at that bad boy look at
look at those pistons for a boat man
yeah that's a boat engine I remember he
looked he looked at there was a pause he
goes to boat engine I was like a yeah
yeah all right man okay oh I'll see you
later yeah I'm not big on boats but cars
I don't know my boats I'll see you later
man cars only see you later thanks for
the bag of fries and chips all right kid
that it that's it all right guys love
you we're out